sekito is tough even for seoul's fans
especially for seoul's fans actually
your muscle memory works against you in
this game but instead of leaving an
embarrassing review on metacritic and
stick with it because honestly the
combat could become your favorite of any
fromsoftware game like it has for me
this video contains tips for those that
are struggling and also fascinating
little details that I guarantee even the
most seasoned player has missed first
did you know
sekito actually comes with difficulty
settings and finally right after you
defeat the chained ogre make a right at
the samurai general and jump onto this
branch past the small hut look for a
grabbable ledge move into the cave with
headless in it and escape out the back
to sin po temple ringing this Bell
curses you with increased difficulty but
it blesses you with increased item drops
enemies actually don't become much
harder but bosses do so remove it before
you fight a boss yeah my first tip for
new players is make the game harder but
um hear me out because now that you have
the Bell demon active for better
crafting material drops we can talk
about grinding it's honestly something
that I recommend every player does at
least once because not only does it give
you gold experience extra healing items
and crafting materials you'll hone your
combat skills in a predictable
environment which means that you'll
actually see yourself become more
efficient at taking out all of these
enemies the best early game location for
grinding is undoubtedly I think the
first stretch of the Hirata estates
where enemies give 34 experience 23 gold
pellets and also rare crafting materials
like scrap iron and even black gunpowder
now there are two items you absolutely
should use up while grinding green and
gold me booth balloons before you start
killing enemies pop the green mibu
balloon which increases item drop rate
however don't pick any of it up yet when
you've finished killing your entire runs
worth of enemies then pop the gold mibu
balloon which increases gold acquisition
and it actually applies retroactively
Lee to all of the gold that
left on the ground which means you can
run back through the area listen to the
sweet sweet sound of gold clinking and
then start a new run killing a few more
enemies for gold before that balloon
buff disappears it's very efficient this
whole process should give you at least
four experience points to spend and
there are three skills I consider to be
baseline for anybody
first there's my kitty in the shinobi
art tree there are tons of enemies that
have devastating perilous thrust attacks
and by dashing towards them mckiddy
gives you what is actually a very very
forgiving option to completely nullify
that damage and you also deal a bit of
posture damage as well after this you
can invest in suppressed presence which
drastically improves your stealth next
in the prosthetic art tree
chasing slice a skill that's really
really good with the shuriken arm and
honestly the shuriken is probably the
best prosthetic for general combat it's
cheap it allows you to interrupt enemies
it allows you to finish off weak enemies
and you can chain together combos and
enemies really really well use this if
you have a ton of gold and you're at a
loss as to what to invest it in you
should always have options the best
option is gold pouches
these are consumable bags of your own
money that prevent it being lost upon
death they cost about 10 percent of the
gold that you spend on them but you will
always get value from these considering
you're gonna lose 50% of that gold if
you die so buy them whenever you see
them seriously if you have nothing else
to invest in you can buy spirit emblems
which actually only cost 10 gold at the
start of the game when you do die you
spread dragon rot which reduces your
chance of receiving unseen aid a lot of
people ask me what type of death spreads
dragon runts so here's the answer only
true death spreads dragon rot if you die
and resurrect that death does not spread
dragon rot if you have a field that you
might die because you're out of gourd or
something just peace out instead every
player now has a home wood Idol which
unlike in previous games can be used to
teleport
back to a checkpoint for free this way
you won't lose half your experience you
can invest your gold and those around
you won't get dragon cancer if your
quickselect bar ever starts to feel
cluttered remember holding down left or
right on the d-pad will immediately skip
you to the first item on your bar which
should always be your healing gourd
honestly I'd recommend you only ever
keep gourd and pellets on your bar the
rest are items that you can just use
situationally in the pause menu and
pellets are really good you get a ton of
them throughout the game of course you
may not like where your buttons are for
heal and I can't blame you the controls
are bit strange however everyone can now
rebind buttons at will and most players
I think will prefer having triangle or Y
as heal and up on the d-pad to switch
prosthetic weapons instead this lets you
move around with the left thumbstick and
heal at the same time
speaking of button presses have you ever
wondered what happens if you don't take
the second R one deathblow offered on
main bosses this happens if you ever
died an embarrassing amount to a boss
looking at you lady butterfly now you
can show them what it's like to die over
and over again one button I guarantee
most of you haven't pressed is triangle
or Y when you're in the travel screen
this opens up an antique map which is
this beautiful little piece of art that
expands as you explore more areas but in
order to explore that map you're going
to have to be good at combat and to
follow here are 10 powerful
underappreciated mechanics that exist in
combat these are things that struggling
players need to know and that even
experienced players might be overlooking
first consider resetting stealth if you
get spotted hop a few fences stay out of
line of sight for a little while and
sometimes with enemies like the chain
Doga for example they'll actually turn
their back on you as they return to
their standing point which puts them in
a position where a stealth kill is
possible where usually they weren't even
possible before the strategy works
pretty well against mini bosses like
they should
be hunter or Jew so bosses that have a
ton of smaller enemies that you're going
to want to stealth kill one at a time
before engaging them now while stealth
can get pretty cheesy combat is anything
but these first few days have been full
of souls fans realizing that they can't
get away with dodge r1 anymore I do want
to confirm though yes i frames do exist
they exist on jumps and they exist on
Dodgers but enemies now have far far
better tracking because you're supposed
to be deflecting these attacks in a way
most attacks are supposed to track you
and hit you
so don't dodge through them this is a
game about clashing swords and the only
time you should be spacing enemies is
when they do perilous attacks or if
you're facing multiple enemies standing
face-to-face with an enemy is no longer
a dangerous position to be in and a
mountain of positive effects are baked
into blocking let me show you them what
you're seeing here is attack cancelling
enabling a block as long as the actual
swing isn't in motion this is why it's
important not to spam r1 attacks like
you can in Souls games this will queue
your attacks you'll do more than you
intend to and it'll make it harder to
block cancel instead consciously tap r1
once every time you attack so that
you're always fully in control this way
your enemy will eventually power through
your assault and you will be ready to
start blocking at a moment's notice
few new players understand just how
powerful a tool blocking is it prevents
all damage it can be used to inflict
posture damage it comes out at a
moment's notice and you can also recover
posture twice as fast while blocking
look at this so if you don't need to
move out of the way of anything and
you're just waiting block should be your
standard position and a super opie
technique that few people are utilizing
is repeatedly tapping block as fast as
you can while being attacked
it repeats so fast that it's actually
impossible to get hit through it and it
also gives you a decent chance at
deflecting a blow don't do this all the
time obviously you still have to think
but if you have a feeling overwhelmed by
a flurry of attacks you can just spam
that block and try to keep up with them
at best you deflect some attacks at
worst your posture gets overwhelmed and
bear in mind most enemies can't even
necessarily capitalize on breaking your
posture so you might not even take
damage if you roll fast enough another
reason spam tapping is important is
because of another mechanic called
consecutive deflect which increases the
posture damage you do for deflecting
multiple hits in a row many enemies have
flurry attacks these are attacks that
are a huge opportunity for you you want
to see flurry attacks sing the pacing in
your head for example this enemy is one
two three four one two three four five
one and now I'm actually happy to see
this attack coming my way
sekito is in no small way a rhythm game
if you do take an unblocked hit you'll
actually notice your character falling
off balance this stumble can be resolved
by blocking or dodging and as you can
probably guess blocking is better your
recovery is actually immediate if you
turn it into a deflect enemies can get
perfect deflects as well and while they
don't reduce your posture they do affect
the flow of your attacks giving you a
brief pause and putting you back to the
first attack in your sequence enemies
can use this pause to launch a combo of
their own so if you notice them starting
their own combo just let it happen go on
the defensive combat is now about
trading offense and defense and defense
is just as big an opportunity as
offenses another opportunity you're
probably not making use of is your jump
kick so basically any enemy can be
double jumped on enabling a tiny bit of
damage with a double r1 but something
that most players overlook
is that you actually deal a ton of
posture damage if you jump kick a
perilous sweep attack look at this so
next time you intuitively jump away from
an enemy jump on them instead
finally posture is linked to your health
when a posture bar is glowing red it
means health is low and posture will
regenerate slowly to kill most of the
later bosses in the game you actually
have to be very aware of opportunities
that allow you to deal health damage
because posture damage at the beginning
of the fight is going to be worthless
one such example of this is against lady
butterfly who suffers greatly against
repeated dodge attacks and should akan
throws when she's jumping between wires
if you're appreciative of any of these
tips or maybe you're running low on
t-shirts or hoodies then consider
checking out the merge section down
below the video a lot of you guys
mentioned last time that you wanted a
light version of the last design we made
and my artists and I have obliged demon
via video now looks good and dark
t-shirts and hoodies with a sort of
Miami sunset behind him rather than the
Eclipse I priced it as cheap as I could
make it all of the weapons should look
familiar to you if you're a Souls fan so
hopefully that you feel like is sort of
wrapping the things that you're
passionate about you know that's what I
would want to wear in a shirt so that's
what I made I'll see you in the next one
or on Twitch as we continue my blind
playthrough of sekito link below follow
the stream if you're wondering what I
think of the game I don't want to jump
to conclusions but if it continues at
this pace on this track I think it's
gonna be my favourite from software game
to date the only thing I'm worried about
is replayability and I really want to
know what you guys think of the game
down below do you think it's too hard
too easy let me know and I'll see you
next time
[Music]